what's going on reject nation Greg Albie
here I'm John I know what that was weird
a good time then like you do a good one
that people do transport it on school
yeah it's absolutely true over at
patreon one of the reward tiers is
whatever video you request we must
definitely do we are your slaves Jay and
Valente has weird-ass requests sometimes
which are always exciting to choose from
and the one that seemed most relevant
duplicable for the real rejects yeah
it's gonna be this one of the many that
he submitted as potentials Will Smith on
his competitive friend Michael Jordan I
figure since we saw the movie bright did
you finish right I did yes the whole
thing this would be relevant in terms of
uploads for bright this week he was on
Jimmy Kimmel let's see his interview
William Smithers watch it you're like oh
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
dinner or something
what you know being around people with
that kind of competitive energy but you
know like Michael compete with anything
though like you know we drinking water
you know my god race you okay we try to
beat them or would you if you were
having you know it was in the time
because I considered myself competitive
to uh spend time with them right it's
like it's just a it's another level like
another command of their minds you see
why they win because that kind of
mindset is it's a it's seen it's great
when you're playing basketball or golf
you know it seems like when you're
having dinner you want to like just like
take a walk you don't have to be in the
front and we can just have dinner with
Michael Jordan is he is he like is he
racing you to pick up the check or is he
because he's not good at that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love celebrities I loved famous you
know I also love I love famous people
talking about their famous friends it's
like a cool comic strip that just plays
out in your mind you know they've been
talking about Space Jam to for such a
long time I think the way to do Space
Jam to you bring back Michael Jordan and
you throw Will Smith in there too
dude it's time and you get an ultimate
Space Jam
I actually liked what he said about he
thought he considered herself a
competitive guy until he got to know
Tiger Woods and Michael Jordan yeah cuz
I've seen videos on Will Smith talking
about his work ethic and his mentality
towards you know being more successful
in life he tends to get a movie that
opens up a number at the box-office
excluding seven a few movies like 7
pounds and concussion what's that one oh
the Christmas one yeah that crappy ass
what the hell was that cause they're all
like angels yeah but if he does like a
blockbuster movie those tend to open up
number one and it has to be very
competitive about that I remember when
he was talking about after earth and how
he was so thrown off had I was the first
time like a blockbuster he was in did
not do well yeah I'm night and it really
discouraged him I've seen an interviewer
he's talking about how you know you put
me on a treadmill I'm never getting off
I will keep going until I die that's
just my level of commitment right there
but hearing that there's people out
there that he met her like you know I'm
not that competitive actually compared
to these guys and we can't really some
of the biggest in history I was I was a
huge huge Michael Jordan fan as a kid
man I had everyone was yeah they weren't
in the basketball you were into Michael
Jordan yeah I watch much basketball but
I did watch a lot of Bulls game yeah and
I did try and play basketball along with
the smooth operation smooth operator
yeah see
who can like outstrip Will Smith in
terms of you know a competitive
commitment I guess MJ I believe it I'm
glad he's got friends and seeing that
photo Will Smith of Fresh Prince every
time I catch an episode of Fresh Prince
it's weird how transporting it is I
always this thought that goes off in my
head like he's like a mega movie star
and yeah he blends in so well with this
show that you're not aware of that when
you're watching it we're now if Wilson
other were to like come on a show it
would be like if I can make a movie star
Will Smith right now but when you see
Fresh Prince to see that start and watch
him evolve as an actor on that show he
first starts off he's just funny and
then he has a few episodes that are real
tearjerkers where he gets very emotional
and I started crying
there was like at least three I could
think of with that show to see that
that's where it started and where he's
come now it's incredible like going from
rapper to TV show star to now make a
movie star this guy's had a blossoming
career and now Netflix star the first
ever Netflix this is return TV yeah it
is his return to TV actually in a weird
way he just put out a single earlier
this year did he yeah he did yes
I think it's called get lit or something
he put out a single I don't even know
about that it's not all Jaden Smith
doing the red Will Smith is still in the
game - yeah did he do it first huh I
don't think he I'm glad he's kind of
backed away from the whole trying to
make his son famous James Smith is doing
enough to make himself famous he's
dropping records and educating the
people and and you know - because for a
while they're releasing like Will Smith
was hell-bent on making Jaden famous
Jaden's got that covered now he's got
his own record label apparently I felt
like that's when the the decline of Will
Smith in certain areas of his career
really began I'm like quit shoving your
family in my face pursuit of happiness
is all right buddy then you're producing
the Karate Kid and you're doing after
earth you know that was a cool novelty
but I don't need like a franchises worth
of films around like
the father and son do but yeah guys keep
a lookout for a review of bright it
might be up before this video actually
hey who knows who knows Thank You Jay
and Valente for sending us our way your
shirt that you received gives you pledge
for a certain amount to get one of our
t-shirts it's on its way buddy keep a
look out for that you're all the way in
Portugal so it's gonna take a while to
get there but it's going subscribe to
the real rejects quick that notification
bell you can find John and I on
patreon.com slash the real rejects it's
like a second youtube channel over there
raw and of course for higher pledges or
some extra little special cuddles other
than that this was a daily content doing
a lot of music video reactions lately
yeah check it